on trouve tout de suite michel fize
sociologue auteur du livre une
insurrection populaire au destin encore
incertain bonsoir avoue michel fize
merci d'être en direct avec nous je
disais que l'auteur d'une insurrection
populaire au destin encore incertain
spina insurrection populaire à laquelle
on assiste chaque samedi maintenant
depuis trois semaines je crois que mon
livre est toujours d'actualité
et par rapport à ce que je viens
d'entendre je crois qu'il faut souligner
que le mécontentement dépasse le clivage
gauche droite etc c'est véritablement
l'ensemble des français qui aujourd'hui
s'indigne de tous ces tâtonnements que
l'on voit se répéter
jour après jour tant en ce qui concerne
la gestion de la crise sanitaire que la
gestion de la crise économique
et puis ce à quoi nous sommes
aujourd'hui confrontés c'est à une crise
des libertés ce qui permet d'ailleurs de
dire que on avait coutume de dire
qu'entre l'égalité et la liberté
les français préféré légalité et ben je
crois qu'ils sont fortement attachés aux
libertés quand ils voient une menace une
menace se profile et alors je crois que
ce mouvement est un mouvement quand même
important encore aujourd'hui et je
rappelle ce que j'ai souvent dit à
propos des gilet jaune
ce n'est pas le nombre qui fait la force
si la détermination et je crois que nous
repartons 20 à un rituel de colère que
nous avons connu pendant deux ans avec
avec les gilet jaune alors les gilets
jaunes justement qu'ils souhaitaient
manifester aujourd'hui ils ont été
interdits
de se mobiliser votre analyse par
rapport à cela
démarche possible à paris et puis d'un
côté on empêche le gilet jaune de
manifester alors les gilet jaune était à
l'intérieur de ceux de ce mouvement
éparpillé avec avec d'autres ce qui
permet de dire que dans cette réunion
d'aujourd'hui à paris et dans une
cinquantaine de villes de provence
il n'y avait pas des représentants
d'extrême gauche inde et désireux de
mettre à bas ce système politique
il ya simplement des français qui
veulent encore une fois que leur liberté
soit soit préservée et que les policiers
ne soient pas mieux traités que les
autres citoyens
encore une fois je crois que les
policiers ont droit à être bien traité
mais pas mieux que l'ensemble des autres
des autres citoyens
bon c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que on fait un débat à propos de
cet article 24 de la loi sur la sécurité
globale
alors qu'en réalité l'article 18 du
projet de loi sur le renforcement des
principes républicains prévoient très
clairement de protéger tout citoyen dont
la diffusion par quelque moyen que ce
soit de 200 images porterait atteinte à
son intégrité
il n'est pas nécessaire me semble-t-il
d'aller plus loin en faisant un texte
spécifique pour les policiers encore une
fois les policiers sont des citoyens
comme les autres et on doit et hongrois
pardon à la même protection que tous les
autres citoyens
vous estimez vous que c'est un recul de
la part du gouvernement la réécriture de
l'article 24
cet article 24 fait redondance avec
l'article 18 du du projet de loi encore
une fois sur les principes sur les
principes républicains donc là on
al'impression évidemment d'un combat un
petit peu un petit peu de
d'arrière-garde
maintenant je pense que le défi qui va
se poser face à un fait qui
malheureusement n'est pas n'est pas
contestable et beaucoup de manifestants
peuvent s'en plaindre il n'y a pas de
cristallisation des mécontentements
il n'y a pas de solidifier
solidification décolère pas de
convergence des luttes
donc les combats se succèdent les uns
les autres les gilet jaune qui ont été
suivis par les cheminots les avocats les
enseignants et aujourd'hui par tous ceux
qui sont attachés à la défense des
libertés
donc il ya une succession de
mécontentement qui finalement protège
quelque part le régime le régime
politique mais je crois qu'il faut
surtout rappeler par rapport à cette
question d'insécurité c'est que la
france est aujourd'hui en état
d'insécurité globale que ce soit la
sécurité sanitaire qui perdure
l'insécurité économique sociale dont on
verra peut-être mieux les effets dans
quelques dans quelques mois
l'insécurité culturel on le voit avec
les apps les théâtres les cinémas tous
les lieux de spectacles qui restent qui
reste fermé donc je pense que ce que les
français disent aujourd'hui ils ne
veulent pas d'ordre les français ils ne
veulent pas d'autorité il vole la
sécurité ils veulent la sécurité sociale
la sécurité économique ils veulent vivre
dignement dans un pays qui se réclame
pays démocratiques pour terminer
rapidement
michel fize vous n'êtes pas de
convergence des luttes
est-ce qu'on va hier est-ce qu'on va y
venir à cette convergence des luttes et
quelles conséquences si on y arrive à je
crois que c'est l'objectif dans
l'inconscient collectif de tous ceux qui
depuis deux ans maintenant son sang dans
la rue mais je crois que
l'individualisme que nous subissons tous
quelque part c'est le parapluie du
régime politique actuel
c'est cet individualisme cette absence
de de repères collectifs d'organisations
collectives comme on pouvait évidemment
en connaître il ya encore une
cinquantaine d'années bas tout ça un
petit peu un petit peu disparu voilà je
pense qu'il faut il faut reconstruire
une société
et dire que finalement l'état n'a plus
le monopole ni de la démocratie c'est à
dire une version représentative la
démocratie qu'il n'a certainement pas le
monopole de la violence légitime
l'état est autorisée
cette contrainte à user de la force dans
des circonstances exceptionnelles mais
en aucun cas faire preuve faire preuve
de violence
merci beaucoup à vous michel fize
sociologue auteur du livre à une
insurrection populaire au destin encore
à un certain merci à vous